[Music]
on this thursday night horrifying error
in quebec
what first responders discovered in the
woods the colossal mistake they made and
the apology to a grieving family anxiety
over alberta's plan to scrap its
pandemic protocols including quarantine
for those with covid19
just want to like be safe right the
fears it's happening
too soon immunization mission new
tactics from the u.s president to push
the reluctant
to roll up their sleeves and she the
north
they are giving us so much to cheer for
how
women are hauling in the hardware for
canada at the olympics
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a troubling story that
defies explanation police in sherbrooke
quebec
say they and the fire department mistook
a human body
found burning in the woods for a
mannequin and dumped it in a garbage bin
it wasn't until about eight hours later
after a man reported his wife
missing that they realized their
terrible mistake mike armstrong is
following this for us and a warning the
details
are disturbing mike well donna this is a
hard story to believe
it is a major mistake made by police and
firefighters
working together
the sherbet police chief walked through
the details this afternoon of what went
wrong
it started with a 9-1-1 call last friday
just after 10 a.m
for a brush fire when police arrived at
the scene witnesses said they'd seen
someone
burning a mannequin firefighters arrived
the fire was put out and the decision
was made
to dispose of the mannequin in a
dumpster at the police station
now at 2 15 that same afternoon a man
called and reported his wife
missing police tracked her cell phone
and found her vehicle
it turned out to be on the same street
where the fire had been
some of the officers started to ask if
the two incidents could be related
at 6 30 that evening they checked the
dumpster and realized the mannequin
they'd thrown away in the garbage
was in fact the missing woman
the fire chief says what happened has
shocked everyone involved not only are
they investigating the major mistake
they're also having to manage the
emotional
toll it's taken on the team now on top
of trying to explain the error
there appears to be a murderer on the
loose and the mistake that was made
won't help not only has time being lost
where police could have been looking
but the crime scene has been turned
upside down and potentially
important evidence lost donna
really an unbelievable story mike
armstrong in montreal tonight thanks
how to handle what happens next with
covid19 is triggering quite a debate
in alberta it has decided to treat
covid19 like
other respiratory viruses close contacts
of those who test positive no longer
have to self-isolate and soon
even those who test positive for covid19
themselves will no longer have to
quarantine
alberta's chief medical officer says the
new approach is possible
because so many people are vaccinated
alberta is not
leading the way though with vaccine
uptake atlantic canada leads the country
with first doses
prince edward island and newfoundland
and labrador more than 77 percent of the
population there has received at least
one dose
none of it has the lowest percentage in
the country just over 57 percent
in alberta almost 64 of people have had
at least
one shot that leaves a big group of
people mostly young people
unprotected and though learning to live
with covet is the long-term goal of
every country
medical experts say there is a risk in
moving too fast heather yorick's west
reports
you want more swing it's been a long 18
months for brooke boning the calgary
mother says her family is ready to move
on from covet 19.
i think life eventually just needs to go
back to normal and
people are getting vaccinated boning
says she was happy to hear the province
is moving away from its pandemic
response plan
scaling back testing and contact tracing
even dropping the legal requirement that
those who test positive for the virus
quarantine but within the medical
community
there is plenty of concern i don't want
to take this on i don't want to take on
this government
i just want to just want to like be safe
right
like that's the only reason why i've
ever fought is so my kids are safe
there is a general feeling of shock
amongst the colleagues i work with in
the hospital
that we're doing the absolute wrong
thing that's because alberta's
vaccination rate is far below what's
required to hit community-wide
protection
i think the concern remains that we have
over a million unvaccinated albertans
rapid viral spread and those people are
at risk of perhaps severe illness
hospitalization and even worse outcomes
across the country
the number of new daily covet infections
is beginning to rise
it's why most other provinces have
remained cautious
keeping much of their pandemic response
plans intact
we are going to continue with a pathway
that keeps the vast majority of ontario
citizens
safe and hope that people do the right
thing
and get vaccinated as soon as they can
alberta's top doctor says the province
needs to shift resources to prepare for
other health threats like the expected
return of the seasonal flu
still dr dina hinshaw says kofit 19
has not gone away and if required the
province's response plan
could change again if we see a new
variant that's spreading that
vaccines don't protect against if we're
seeing
a surge particularly in a localized area
a surge in cases that's leading
to severe outcomes then we absolutely
will be looking at interventions in
those locations
but other than that alberta is turning
the page
launching a province-wide experiment on
whether now is the time
to do this safely heather urex west
global news
calgary the u.s is on a different path
vaccination rates have dropped off there
even though the country has more than
enough doses for everyone
and that is prolonging the crisis today
president joe biden jolted the holdouts
with a tough new approach with freedom
comes responsibility
so please exercise responsible judgment
get vaccinated for yourself
for the people you love for your country
he is not making vaccines mandatory but
he is coming close
the aim is to make being unvaccinated
such a hassle and so restrictive that
people roll up their sleeves
jackson prosco on president biden's plea
to the unvaccinated
in a return to the worst days of the
pandemic hospitals in parts of the u.s
are nearing the breaking point
two-thirds of u.s counties once again
have high or substantial levels of virus
transmission
this delta variant that we're seeing now
changes the game
from my perspective despite ample access
to vaccines
only half of eligible americans are
fully vaccinated
the pace of inoculation has slowed to a
fraction of what it was in the spring
we're at the point now where one
individual's
refusal to get vaccinated it's having an
impact on other people
and when your actions compromise the
health of someone else
that's when i an appropriate time to
intervene in the form of a mandate
frustrated by the stalled vaccination
effort and the surging virus
president joe biden is calling for 100
payments to newly vaccinated americans
and is giving millions of government
workers an ultimatum
get the shot or face mandatory testing
and on-the-job restrictions
you want to know how we put this virus
behind us i'll tell you how we need to
get more people vaccinated
corporate america is going further
facebook and google will require
vaccination for all employees who return
to the office
some restaurants have decided to make
vaccination mandatory for both employees
and customers
we can talk about so many other issues
with covey but we're not talking about
vaccination then we're not talking about
the solution
you want a recovery you need vaccination
in a country
so split over vaccines ethicists warn
pushing too hard or mandating
vaccination
could actually backfire we have to be
pretty clear that we've tried
everything and that everyone including
vulnerable people has had full access to
the vaccines before we make a decision
of that
magnitude with the virus once again
circulating widely and spreading rapidly
scientists warn this half-vaccinated
nation will need to do more
quickly the only thing that's going to
limit the spread
is a combination of regular testing
mask mandates and really making sure
that
everyone is vaccinated
the president has also directed the
pentagon to determine when the kovic 19
vaccines can be added to the list of
mandatory vaccines for members of the
u.s military
and of course donna the backdrop to all
of this is the fact that masks are once
again mandatory in many parts of this
country
regardless of vaccination status
jackson the president can't tell states
and private companies what to do
but he did send a strong message today
that they can force employees to get
vaccinated or get regular tests
what did he say that's right he says
he's looked into this and
yes companies can mandate vaccinations
if they want local jurisdictions can do
it as well
whether or not the federal government
could do that on a national scale
remains an open question according to
the president
but donna you can bet one way or another
these mandates no matter how big or how
small they are
will all but certainly end up in court
challenges
all right jackson proskow in washington
thanks
an american is one of two pole vaulters
at the olympics who have tested positive
for kovid 19 and are out of the
competition
sam kendricks won a bronze in 2016 and
is a double world champion
i have no recourse but to sit
in isolation and watch the olympics
kendrick's positive test result sent the
entire australian track team into brief
quarantine three of them had come into
contact with kendricks
they've since tested negative a pole
vaulter from argentina
also has coveted and is also no longer
competing
canada has five new senators they are
independents recommended by the
independent advisory board for senate
appointments and
appointed by the new governor general
here are the faces who will fill five of
the 105
seats in the red chamber they're an
eclectic mix representatives from
alberta saskatchewan and quebec
michelle odette was a commissioner for
the national inquiry into missing and
murdered indigenous women and girls
karen sorensen was the mayor of banff
you can read more about all the
appointees
on our website globalnews.ca
globalnational
for the first time a former american
cardinal in the catholic church has been
charged with sexually abusing
a minor 91 year old theodore mccarrick
faces three counts of indecent assault
and battery on a person over 14.
the alleged incident happened at a
wedding reception in 1974.
the boy was 16 at the time mccarrick was
defrocked by
pope francis in 2019 after a vatican
investigation found he sexually molested
adults and children
mccarrick is the highest ranking
catholic church official criminally
accused
in the sex abuse scandal in the church
that's gone on for decades
pointing the finger at malta's
government coming up why it's being
blamed for the assassination
of an investigative journalist plus
raging infernos the deadly wildfires
decimating turkey's coast
and a slice of history on the auction
block
what's so special about this 40 year old
piece of cake
crews are struggling to contain multiple
fires burning in southern turkey dozens
of fires have erupted across the region
at least three people have died
and dozens are injured 30 villages are
under evacuation orders as strong winds
and
hot weather fan the flames an
investigation into what caused the fires
is underway it's suspected some were
acts of arson
a public inquiry into the assassination
of an investigative journalist in malta
has found the state
is responsible for her death daphne
caruana galicia was killed by a car bomb
as she drove from her home in malta
in october 2017. the 53-year-old
journalist was described as a one-woman
wikileaks who exposed corruption in her
country and abroad
the inquiry found the state created an
atmosphere of impunity at the highest
echelons of power and failed to
recognize
risks to her life and take reasonable
steps to avoid them
her murder caused outrage across europe
and the investigation led to the
resignation of then prime minister
joseph muscat
last year after his close associates
were implicated
keeping covet out but letting loved ones
in still ahead the pressure on hospitals
to allow
visitors
going through medical treatment is
stressful enough having to do it alone
makes it all worse
yet in many hospitals strict no visitor
policies put in place at the start of
the pandemic
still exist only now when so many people
are vaccinated for covet 19
they may be doing more harm than good
karen lieberman reports
i was pre-diagnosed with stage four
metastatic breast cancer
about a year ago for the last few years
heather lisa of london ontario has been
fighting to save lives
first on the front lines helping others
as a respiratory therapist
and now as a cancer patient undergoing
treatment
it's terrifying it's lonely it's um
it's confusing lisa has had to do it all
alone
to get my diagnosis by myself with
i had my husband on the phone
was i can't even describe it restaurants
in ontario are once again filled with
patrons moviegoers can flock to theaters
but in many cases loved ones can only
provide support to family members
undergoing medical treatment
from a distance we didn't have enough
ppe we didn't know enough about kobed
during the first wave fearing the spread
of covid19 and experiencing a surge of
patients
hospitals closed their doors to visitors
now there are calls to loosen
restrictions
family and essential care partners with
strict infection
prevention control measures do not play
a major role in the transmission of
covet
into the hospital when diane guy of
belleville suffered a stroke her husband
called 9-1-1
she was rushed to hospital and underwent
surgery alone
i'm in there and i'm my my mind is just
gone
i'm just petrified and the doctors
talking to me and i had no idea what
they were saying or anything
the impact of strict no visitor policies
at hospitals across canada was felt not
only by the sick
in addition to caring for patients we
found ourselves also being
placeholders for their families at
toronto's humber river hospital
effective this month a move to safely
reintroduce family to the bedside
prior to this we had 24 7 open visiting
and so we're not quite there yet but we
are a step closer
but visitor policies vary from one
hospital to the next
one unit to another heather lisa is
hopeful to have her family at her side
for her next appointment i don't see a
reason why a fully vaccinated
family member wouldn't be able to
accompany me to you
to appointments at this stage karen
lieberman
global news toronto
a slice of history is up for auction in
england four decades after it was served
it may not be quite as fresh as it was
at the wedding of charles and diana in
1981 when there were 23 official wedding
cakes served but
this slice is considered precious a
member of the queen mother's household
kept it
preserving it in plastic wrap inside a
tin the slice is expected to fetch
somewhere between
four hundred and seven hundred dollars
when it's auctioned off next month
oh and the auction house says we advise
against eating it
just in case you need that advice
a woman's place is on the podium next
team canada keeps hauling in the medals
canada's most decorated summer olympian
penny alexiac could break another record
tonight
a podium finish in the 100-meter
freestyle final would make her the only
canadian with seven olympic medals
global news spoke to penny's mother and
sister today ahead of the big race
we're probably way more stressed than
she is or maybe it's just me that stress
well my mom is very suspicious so she
makes us all
come to the same spot now every day
because after her first race went well
they were all sitting in the same spot
my mom's insistent that we all
come to the same spot
alexiak is inspired by american swimmer
michael phelps the most decorated
olympian of all time
her family says she speaks to him on a
regular basis
and i think hearing from him that you
know you really don't need to feel like
the you know the weight of the world's
on you
you know as long as you're focused on
what you want to do
and you're comfortable and you're happy
with what you've done and you feel that
you've put all your
energy and effort into it to be the best
that you can be um
that's enough and i think he you know
hearing that from him
i think really took on a different
perspective for her and i think really
helped her
such good advice penny alexia is part of
team canada's strong start at the tokyo
games after six days of competition
canada has ten medals two gold three
silver and five bronze
putting us in 12th spot for total number
of medals
all 10 of those medals have been won by
female athletes
it is inspiration to younger athletes
setting their sights on future olympics
redmond shannon looks at why the women
are dominating the start of these games
kaylee filmer and hilary johnson's take
bronze
in the coxless pairs it means as of
thursday
team canada's medal tally is 10
10-0 for the women from swimming to
softball
lifting to diving it's all about the
women
this is just a huge celebration of women
in sport and
they are giving us so much to cheer for
and really to be proud of
one reason for this could be simple math
at recent summer games
far more canadian women qualified for
events than men
and that is being reflected in the medal
count with
female athletes outshining their male
teammates
another reason could be the schedule
many sports with a legacy of
female canadian success are in the first
week
there's no question that swimming and
rowing are just
powerful for us but also we've made some
breakthroughs with judo
and non-traditional women's sport angela
schneider won silver in the cox fours in
the
less equal days of 1984 but even then
she noticed why canadian women could
succeed
i was so shocked when i went there to
see the way
other women were treated we were
we were treated so well in our country
comparatively speaking
in the pool canadian women and sport is
an organization that works to
help girls stay with sports even in
canada girls are
three times more likely than boys to
quit sports in their teenage years
they lose confidence in their body image
they lose confidence in their
skills as they go through those teen
years
sport can be a place when we're aware of
that sort of thing okay let's design
to counteract those sorts of things
alison sandmar graves says the recent
controversy over the norwegian handball
team uniforms
was an example of why women can feel
uncomfortable
in sports success she says is making
more girls
feel welcome olympic medals are a happy
bonus
more than a final goal redmond shannon
global news
london and that is global national for
this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is this beautiful
field of sunflowers
and lorette manitoba matches my jacket
thanks for watching
neetu garcia will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow and i'll see you again
in august take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye